first we are once again asking office
workers
who can work from home to do so in key
public services and in all
professions where homeworking is not
possible
such as construction or retail people
should continue
to attend their workplaces and like
government this house will be free to
take forward its business
in a covered secure way which you mr
speaker
have pioneered second
from thursday all pubs bars
and restaurants must operate a table
service only mr speaker except for
takeaways
together with all hospitality venues
they must close
at 10 p.m and to help the police enforce
this rule i'm afraid
that means alas closing and not just
calling for last orders because
simplicity is paramount the same will
apply to takeaways
though deliveries can continue
thereafter i'm sorry
that this will affect many businesses
just getting back on their feet but we
must act
to stop the virus from being transmitted
in bars
and restaurants third we will
extend the requirement to where face
coverings to include
staff in retail all users of taxis
and private hire vehicles and staff and
customers
in indoor hospitality except when seated
at a table to eat
or drink fourth in retail leisure and
tourism and other sectors
our covered secure guidelines will
become legal
obligations businesses will be fined
and could be closed if they breach the
rules
fifth now is the time to tighten up the
rule of six
i'm afraid that from monday a maximum of
15 people
will be able to attend wedding
ceremonies and
receptions though up to 30 i can still
attend
a funeral as now we will also have to
extend the rule of six to all adult
indoor team sports
finally we have to acknowledge that the
spread of the virus is now
affecting our ability to reopen business
conferences exhibitions
and large sporting events so
we will not be able to do this from the
first of october and i recognize the
implications for our sports clubs
which are the life and soul of our
communities
and my right-hand friends the chancellor
and culture secretary are working
urgently on what we can do now to
support them
mr speaker these rules these measures
will only work if people comply and that
there is nothing more
frustrating for the vast majority
who do comply the law-abiding majority
than the site of a
few are brazenly defying the rules so
these rules will be enforced by tighter
penalties